رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه في قمه المناخ
بشرم الشيخ فيما جدلن جديد يلاحقه وهذه
المره على خلفيه تعيينه جبن وليامسين
وزيرا بالرغم من مزاعم التنمر على زميله
نائبه له في حزب المحافظين هذه الفضيحه
الجديده تتمثل في ارسال رسائل نصيه مليئه
بالشتائم الى مسؤوله الانضباط داخل الحزب
في البرلمان
لاستبعادها نبا ومن بينهم وليامسين من
حضور جنازه الملكه اليزا مكتب رئيس
الوزراء كان على علم بالشكوى ضد وليام قبل
تعيينه لكنه لم يكن مطلعا على مضمون
الرسائل التي وصفها بغير المقبوله والحزب
يحقق فيها
ارسال هذه الرسائل التي ارى انها قد تمت
بسبب الاحباط والانفعاله ولكن اعتقد عموما
انه من الافضل كتابه اشياء لن تندم عليها
لاحقا وخاصه مع من يكتب من الزملاء اشياء
مهذبه وان كانت لتعبير عن وجهه نظر مختلفه
الرسائل كانت غير منطقيه سوكر ستار مره
زعيم حزب العمال المعارض دعا سوناك الى
اقاله جيفن وليامسين واصفا ياه بغير لائق
كوزين في الحكومه والذي سبق ان اقيل من
حكومه الترزامي وتم استبداله في عهد
جونسون عندما كان وزير للتعليم ومنذ
استلامه السلطه تعرض سوناك للانتقادات
كبيره بدءا من اعاده التعيين سويلا دراما
وزيره للداخليه بعد ان اعترفت باستخدام
بريدها الالكتروني الخاص مرارا للقيام
باعمال الحكوميه مخالفه للقواعد الوزاريه
الى قراره بعدم المشاركه في قمه المناخ في
مصر ثم تراجعه تحت الضغط وصولا اخيرا الى
فضيحه رسائلي وليامسن المسيئه
الجدل يلاحق السوناك منذ التعيينات التي
اجراها لاعضاء حكومته والتي اعتبرتها
المعارضه على ما تضعفه سلسله الانتقادات
هذه لا تبدو نهايتها وشيكه مع الترقب
الكشفي عن تفاصيل موازنه جديده ستكون
مؤلمه لدافع الضرائب ومزود الخدمات العامه